so for the last couple of days every few
hours we have like five additional
percent of the Donald Trump Joe Biden
Ukraine withholding aid Fiasco confirmed
and we're closer and closer to just
being able to say the entire story as
reported is true now to reset the story
what we're talking about here is a
report that Donald Trump ordered Ukraine
to smear Joe Biden if they want 250
million dollars in military aid plus
some other rate it now it appears and
otherwise they don't get it and this was
allegedly discussed during a phone call
between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president back in July we now know that
Rudy Giuliani was pulled in to work on
this and we're talking about corruption
bribery the term collusion is being
thrown around I mean really beyond the
pale to such a degree that even American
law may be ill-equipped to deal with
what it is that the president is doing
here and the initial reaction from
Donald Trump was everything's fine like
not necessarily denying the particular
elements of the story but saying we had
a totally normal normal phone call
everything's fine
the story is bogus it's all fake news
etc but slowly and over the period of a
couple of days we get confirmation of
more and more elements of the story
Donald Trump admitting sort of blurting
out really that the topic of Joe Biden
did come up during the July phone call
with the Ukrainian president Donald
Trump admitting that Joe Biden being
supposedly corrupt was a topic of
conversation during the phone call
Donald Trump admits I did want Rudy
Giuliani involved in this entire thing
generally Rudy Giuliani with Chris Cuomo
on CNN admitting he did ask the
Ukrainians to quote investigate Joe
Biden so slowly but surely they deny the
whole story but then admit to almost
every single one of the component parts
well now we have a really big piece of
this which is that the Washington Post
has broken the story that indeed just
days before the July phone call between
Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president
Donald
from ordered military aid be withheld
from Ukraine Donald Trump told his
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
there's still no permanent chief of
staff by the way hold back the money
just a few days before the phone call
according to three senior administration
officials this was then relayed to the
State Department and to the Pentagon now
of course they're going to come up with
and I think they already have actually
some innocuous benign reason for why the
money was ordered withheld something
like Oh Trump thinks there may be better
uses for the money or something like
that but once again another element of
the story is confirmed that the timing
of the money if not the justification
for the money being withheld the timing
of the money being withheld lines up
perfectly with the phone call during
which Donald Trump asked Ukraine to
smear Joe Biden the story is accurate
guys the story is real the story is true
and this is a for people who are now
waiting for consequences to this let me
cut to the end of the story there are
not going to be consequences for this
here's how it's going to go eventually
pressure will build for the transcript
of the phone call with the Ukrainian
president to be released remember that
the White House has a history of editing
transcripts when Donald Trump slips up
and says something stupid so eventually
the White House will acquiesce or at
least pretend to be acquiescing and they
will release a transcript and it will
either be incomplete or it won't show an
explicit quid pro quo only an implied
one and Republicans will say see there's
nothing to see here even if there have
been other conversations about this
which I'm sure there have been then
Democrats will have to come back and say
well listen the quid pro quo doesn't
have to be explicit but it will be just
muddled enough that nothing will happen
and Donald Trump will claim that it's
just another witch-hunt the
whistleblower complaint which is at the
heart of this entire thing will be
suppressed and then it'll be November of
2020 and people will be voting without
Donald Trump having ever had just
for any consequences as a result of this
and I want to remind you this is this is
like the maybe the most important thing
the problem here is not the specifics of
the phone call transcript the White
House is suppressing a whistleblower
complaint as well as the information in
that complaint that's the main story
it's not Biden although we will debunk
the conspiracy theory around Biden a
little bit later in the show it's not
necessarily the transcript of this one
phone call because if this is how Donald
Trump is dealing with Ukraine there is
obviously much more than just this one
phone call that led up to this request
from Ukraine of to Ukraine to smear Joe
Biden the story here is the suppression
of the whistleblower but the Trump
cronies are going to successfully narrow
all of this to being about the content
of one call and the transcript of that
one call and by the way in the context
of the Democratic primary this all
probably helps Joe Biden in the polls I
would not be surprised if next week we
start seeing polls just renewing Joe
Biden's position at the top and cutting
the downward momentum that he's been
experiencing Elizabeth Warren has that
big momentum in the last couple of
months but I predict that all of this
helps to maintain Joe Biden in a solid
lead in the primary will we'll see when
we get new polling next week